how's it going it can't be too loud
honeymoon hi this is my night for
honeymoon we're gonna step up the game
with a quality it's gonna good we're
gonna get underwater shots
if Marseille gets too close at me I'm
spraying over this too close too close
we are going we have landed in Qatar in
the middle of the night it's that big
[Music]
I'm in Bali we're here at the Four
Seasons Hotel and I know everyone's like
oh don't belong the hall any moon how do
you expect me to not show all of this
I love you on the bed very nice you have
it oh that's so sweet
happy honeymoon mrs. mr. and mrs.
Shelburne that's us
look at this it's real my god and then
they even printed our Instagram photo we
haven't even done this oh look even more
they wrote it in chocolate
I haven't even show their room so we're
staying by this resort we have our whole
own area this is a pool and this is the
ocean right here this is gonna be epic
I'm so excited last trip we went it was
Marrakesh but it was only for a couple
days I'm really looking forward to just
relax look at this they have what their
men that's not a water man that's a
cactus no a lessig what are these call
coconut that's what I said we should do
a shop
drink at the same time look or I can
just drink from both for that happy
honeymoon let's pop the chat cherry Wow
is that what you say yeah we haven't
shown the bathtub show the bathtub is
there something you're trying to tell us
for season that's amazing I've never
been in a hotel this good we've been at
some good old house but this one why the
question the camera quality got better
all of a sudden getting married is
awesome I was lame I didn't talk I ain't
pop it on purpose do you want some
scream pad hmm
it's competive bad I kind of want that
keep you want the king for a lifetime of
epicness
[Music]
should i blog with the gopro does this
look good
how does this look hey guys was there
this look do you think I should get some
mm-hmm Ray Ban Raynaud's Bandidos hey
ray Bali got some new specs feeling
fresh feeling young they say kids on
them which stands for cool I do I don't
suck next time
[Music]
whoa so this is one of the statues Wow
damn that is big look how small Mart is
and look up Big Daddy I mean sure
[Music]
Bella colicchio Turtles
that's adorable
Oh No
[Music]
we just got back from hotel and they
leave this cute little after 9:00
there's potatoes on the other end what
[Music]
Wow
hey gamers Bali is epic obligatory GoPro
gym
[Music]
what is so funny
yeah damn I'm already 10 bruh just got
back from surfing and I felt so epic
while surfing and then I look at the
footage I'm like wow cool we're going to
this Beach I don't know why but the taxi
driver took us here see you later
oh no we made a terrible mistake we
shouldn't have come here it's so hot
[Music]
some pretty big waves handle pretty much
the same ways as I had this morning
[Music]
so now we're going to early wash the
temple which is a seaside temple it
looks very very pretty but there's
monkeys everywhere oh my god no no oh my
oh you got you gotta they got the
glasses bye
you ready for some epic view footage
it's much like if you are Wow Wow whoa
I gotta get shot in it
[Music]
they made us a bask oh my god this is
handmade that's in the same with a
ladder and some baleen nation chocolate
this is a traditional balinese box that
is made from tiny slices of bamboo and
weed from local Balinese artists
thank you for seasons and hidden
retreats this has been like beyond
anything we've experienced oh my gosh
this Felix and Mars e on it yo mr. beast
but you never ate bet you never fill the
pool with half full quarter full with
roses got them
[Music]
[Applause]
we found a friend on the road nice walk
damn he's strutting look at this dude
okay another epic day of surfing any
time I ride the wave I'm like this is
the coolest and then I look at the
footage I'm like cool so now we're
heading to a food and another
four-season hotel very nice thanks to
hidden retreats thank you guys okay we
just arrived in the jungle this is
insane you hear the river underneath
damn look at that there's the river
[Music]
so this is our fourth decent villa in
the jungle oh damn
[Music]
incredible got our own pool they
prepared the same way for us happy
honeymoon so cute that's the sweet more
flowers very nice you can take a shower
out there it'd be hard to top the last
of how we arrived but this is this is
pretty close there very even but they're
so amazing I'm so blown away
my set told me to film this tree you're
welcome good morning from the jungle
gamer first stop rice terrace
[Music]
we're here in the rice fields it's
really a big can't really capture it
so you can see people farming over there
the water comes from the mountain goes
down in all the layers rice be made epic
[Music]
now we're heading to the water temple or
you can get cleansed by water which
we're not gonna do okay we did an extra
stop this is the Bali
polina it's free entry and then you get
a tour wait what is this they don't
digest yeah they are
coffee huh they're cute
so this is the coffee after it's been
cleaned it smells really nice
surprisingly so our taxi driver really
recommended this place I think he'd
really just want us to drink the Pooh
coffee not happening taxi driver you
ready to get cleanse
yeah no he said he can okay yeah I'm
gonna dip my head cool get rid of all
the de monetization
[Music]
this is crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
alright we're about to make a wish did
we both miss whoa I got the sickest
shine damn front you see this mmm I'm
grossed out huh no no disgusting we just
had amazing vision sir
very nice now we're going to the monkeys
them take your money cell phone for its
thing look at this dude do not run do
not panic oh god what do I do here
[Music]
mimimi
and we look up and we have a little
friend there
Oh God you see in what is he doing
creeping on us
serious that's so cute
jumps on my face and kills me what so
big
good morning gamers today is our last
day of the honeymoon it's time to jump
in today we're going to do the swing
we're going to this temple and more so
peaceful so we're now at the dawn of
Bharat time Lake it's about an hour from
our hotel and I take back what I said
about peaceful I'm not ready for
spongebob Oh Oh spongebob what did they
do to you oh god it's missing his nose
it's postponed we're back at it again on
the boat
oh man so beautiful
look at the mountains look at the ocean
[Music]
we're heading to the waterfall now
you're very exciting there's a chicken
on the raft
baby chicken we're scaring them away I'm
sorry guys
we're still so high high up I regret
this
here we go
I never seen one that big before that's
amazing look at that
yeah this game someone is meditating
[Music]
time to go closer
that was awesome
but now the stairs oh god we have to go
all the way out
310 here we go damn so pretty
taking a little break a lot of steps do
you think I can rent it
[Music]
bum now this place is a mess
one swing
[Music]
all right we're back at the hotel
time to relax I don't think I've long
anything more after this point but it's
been a seriously amazing honeymoon thank
you so much two hidden retreats for
hooking us up if you want to find out
what hotels we stayed at link in
description check them out they also
have a new honeymoon gift card service
so you can gift a honeymoon to someone
which is obviously a very nice thing to
do
thank you hidden retreats and that's it
hope you guys enjoyed coming along smash
like if you did I know I was like don't
vlog the honeymoon but we did it anyway
Bali was seriously amazing people here
are so nice there's so many things to
see so definitely recommend it and yeah
I'm really glad we picked this place now
we have a long trip back I have a
Minecraft dog that's been sitting down
for a very long time
bye gamers
welcome to behind-the-scenes honeymoon
footage
so cannonball
[Applause]